digamos que tu escuela tiene una
población de 80 estudiantes así que
tenemos 80 estudiantes en la población y
quieres tener un estimado de la altura
promedio en tu población y piensas que
es bastante difícil ir con los 80
estudiantes para medir su altura así que
decides tomar una muestra simple
aleatoria y te parece que es razonable
tomar la altura de 30 estudiantes así
que vas a seleccionar aleatoriamente a
30 estudiantes y vas a calcular su
altura promedio y piensas que quizá éste
es un buen estimado para la altura
promedio de la población y ya que
decidiste hacer esto te preguntas bueno
cómo es que puedo hacerlo como elijo a
estos 30 estudiantes de manera que tenga
confianza de que es aleatorio hay varias
formas en las que puedes hacer esto una
forma de hacerlo es poner en un pedazo
de papel el nombre de cada uno de los
estudiantes de esta población para
después ponerlos todos en un recipiente
y después seleccionar 30 de ellos vamos
a hacerlo digamos que vamos a hacer esto
en orden alfabético así que vamos a
escribir en el primer papelito el nombre
de la primera persona alfabéticamente y
vamos a tener 80 pedazos de papel todos
deben de tener el mismo tamaño y vamos a
poner todos los papelitos en un
recipiente y esto parece una forma muy
básica de hacerlo pero es una forma
bastante efectiva de tener una muestra
simple aleatoria
este es nuestro recipiente que parece
una pecera aquí ponemos todos los
pedacitos de papel luego podemos vendar
los ojos de alguien para que esta
persona saque los papelitos de este
recipiente sin que pueda leer los
nombres de estos y debe elegir los
primeros 30 papelitos sin reemplazarlos
ya que no queremos elegir dos veces a la
misma persona y esos 30 nombres elegidos
van a ser los de los estudiantes a los
que se les va a tomar la medida de su
altura serán nuestra muestra simple
aleatoria esta es una forma
completamente legítima de hacerlo otra
forma de hacerlo si es que tienen una
computadora o una
q la dora es usar la función de
generación de números aleatorios por lo
general las funciones aleatorias en los
lenguajes de programación de las
computadoras y las calculadoras
normalmente están en inglés y lucen algo
parecido a esto más punto range que en
inglés significa matemáticas punto
aleatorio o una función random que en
inglés significa aleatorio si no le
pasamos a algún argumento pues nos puede
dar algún número entre 0 y 1 o entre 0 y
100 hay que tener cuidado sobre cómo
usamos estas funciones para que todos
los números tengan la misma oportunidad
de ser elegidos y si ustedes tienen
acceso a algún generador de números
aleatorios que de preferencia elija
números entre 1 y 80 incluyendo los lo
que pueden hacer es alinear los nombres
de los estudiantes alfabéticamente y
asignarles cada uno un número por
ejemplo el primer nombre en orden
alfabético
le puedo asignar el número 01 aquí uso
dos dígitos porque me parece un poco más
claro pero si está
usando un generador de números
aleatorios pueden asignarle el número
uno ya que pueden establecer el rango
entre 1 y 80 y además esto de poner los
dígitos va a ser consistente con otro
método que vamos a ver más adelante el
siguiente nombre en orden alfabético va
a ser el número 02 así continuamos hasta
llegar al número 79 y el último nombre
será el número 80 y usamos nuestro
generador de números aleatorios para que
elija números aleatorios entre 1 y 80 y
siempre y cuando no tengamos algún
número repetido vamos a elegir los
primeros 30 números que me genere esta
función y esos serán los elementos de
nuestra muestra simple aleatoria otra
técnica relacionada que es un poco más
de la vieja escuela pero que
definitivamente es una de las formas que
se ha usado mucho en el pasado e incluso
actualmente se sigue usando es usar una
tabla de dígitos aleatorios vamos a
comenzar igualmente con esta asociación
de números de dos dígitos a cada nombre
para cada estudiante en nuestra pobla
y luego usamos una lista de números
generados aleatoriamente como por
ejemplo esta que continúa más allá de
los números que se muestran aquí y
comenzamos desde el principio nos
interesa tener 30 números de 2 dígitos
desde el 1 al 80 incluyendo al 1 y al 80
así que una técnica es comenzar desde el
principio este es una lista de números
generados aleatoriamente por lo que tomo
este primer número de dos dígitos de
aquí 59-59 está entre 1 y 80 sí sí lo
está si esto hubiera sido un 0 1 hubiera
funcionado si hubiera sido un 80 también
si hubiera sido un 0 0 no hubiera
funcionado y si hubiera sido un 81
tampoco hubiera funcionado así que este
corresponde a el primer nombre que
elegimos es el nombre asociado al número
59 continuamos y elegimos los siguientes
dos dígitos los dos dígitos que siguen
forman el 83 que nunca en el rango que
nos interesa x
lo que no vamos a usarlo ahora vemos los
siguientes dos dígitos y de nuevo
tenemos 59 este número está dentro de
nuestro rango pero ya lo habíamos
elegido así que no lo vamos a usar y
continuamos el que sigue es el 37 y es
un número que está en nuestro rango y
aún no hemos usado así que lo vamos a
usar luego tenemos un 0 0 que no está en
nuestro rango creo que ustedes se dan
cuenta de lo que pasa aquí 91 no está en
nuestro rango así que no nos sirve 23 si
está en nuestro rango y aún no lo hemos
usado así que lo tomamos vamos a
continuar usando esta lista de la forma
que hemos visto aquí hasta que
obtengamos 30 números de estos aquí sólo
tenemos 3 y tendríamos que continuar y
esta no es una lista exhaustiva de todas
las formas diferentes que podemos tener
números aleatorios pero nos da algunas
técnicas en nuestra caja de herramientas
y quizá ustedes me puedan decir bueno y
por qué no yo invento algunos números y
los
pero yo realmente les recomiendo que no
hagan eso ya que los seres humanos somos
muy conocidos por ser muy malos para ser
aleatorios y quizá ustedes quieren usar
algo que ustedes crean que es un proceso
aleatorio pero después se den cuenta de
que realmente no era un proceso
aleatorio así que nuevamente hay varias
técnicas pero estas son algunas de las
mejores prácticas para generar realmente
muestras aleatorias simples